everybody welcome back to awesome bill
where today we're going to be making dr.
poisons masks from Wonder Woman now when
I saw the trailer for the film I saw the
masks and I was like oh that would be a
great build and I know that doesn't me
doing a review coming up so he said that
that's probably something that he's
going to need in the review but he
hasn't seen it yet and hasn't written
the script so we never quite know what
he's going to want when he's going to
need but he did say that that was
probably something to think about if I
had the time to do it before he wrote
the script and got everything ready what
do you when I saw the trailer I thought
that that would be a pretty easy build
to do I could just go to a Halloween
store or a costume shop or something
like that I could just find a cheap mask
kind of like the one that we used for
Shyamalan character that Malcolm plays
and stuff like that and then I could
just take that alter it a little bit cut
out the pieces because it's just mostly
pieces and stuff like that and gloom to
an actor's face so it's basically I did
I went to Party City and I got one of
these cheap masks it's similar to the
one that we used for Shyamalan but it's
a little cheaper is the only one that
they have and they had them in different
colors but it's a little broader along
the face and a little less articulated a
little simpler you could use this
however for me it's a little too simple
than asking I wanted to do something a
little closer to the film and I happen
to have this Halloween mask that I
purchased this past October and was
going to use it for another project I
thought it was just like a cool mask is
really cheap I think I got it maybe it
like a Walgreens or something like that
for like 5 bucks it's a little bit more
durable plastic than this this is really
flimsy this is a little bit more rigid
and it's got some really great
articulation and kind of a cool paint
job actually item set it's a neat
looking mask kind of spooky looking but
I actually I think it looked a lot more
like the mask in the film once you break
it into
components the mask in the movie is has
very earth-like the lips are very
prominent and there are just the
cheekbone elements and stuff like that a
more prominent there's deeper lines and
stuff like that and grooves in the face
so I think actually this mask would work
perfectly this should be actually a
really simple build all we're really
going to need to do is map out on this
mask all the places we're going to make
our cuts based on I have an image
whatever from the movie I'll probably
pull up a few more images after I picked
that one up off the floor and then
cutting it out and I think it's a thin
enough plastic I could do it probably
with some shop sheers or even just a
knife you could use a rotary tool but I
don't know if it's necessary you could
you know it's just thin enough plastic
or I think I could easily cut it with a
pair of scissors then I might use a
rotary tool just to clean up the edges
and stuff like that and round them off a
little bit because some of the edges or
just with a lines and stuff like that
meet on the characters mask in the movie
it's a bit more rounded and there's a
bit of a gap there so that she can speak
and move her mouth and face a little bit
and articulate a little bit more so yeah
we're just going to get started I'm just
going to map out the lines on here and
then we'll just get cutting and shaping
and painting and should be pretty easy
[Music]
Oh
all right so I made my line free happy
with where they're at I'm you know I had
to open it up a little bit on the side
there it was a little little short I
think it's a little bit more around the
cheekbone so I made another line there
and areas like around the nose and stuff
like that I kind of saw for another
picture that kind of bells around the
nose and then comes down a little bit
and then over so yeah I'm going to go
with that start cutting and see how it
all comes up
[Music]
all right so all the pieces are sanded
and ready for painting and I'm going to
use krylon I'm going to give it a base
coat of a flat white and then it's got
to look kind of like a flesh color and
I've got this set and almond color I
think that worked pretty good it's what
I have so I'm going to use it's pretty
close I think cut to a flesh tone I'm
also going to then once it dries do a
bit of a wash inside some of the creases
and stuff like that to kind of make
those a little darker and then make the
other elements pop and the lips do have
almost a pinkish kind of hue to them so
I'm going to very lightly kind of give
those a light wash with a little bit of
like a pink or a peach kind of color so
probably just using some acrylics that I
have lying around so yep it's going to
be a base coat and yeah and we'll go
from there
[Music]
you
all right so that's about it I'm pretty
happy with the way it turned out I think
it's gonna look pretty good on film
we'll just have to wait and see when
Heather comes in and I can apply it all
and see how it looks but I have to make
some modifications here and there but I
think actually overall it's going to
look pretty good pretty close and I'm
just going to apply it using some
basically toupee tape it's men's
grooming tape I use it all the time to
apply different facial appliances and
stuff like that it's great if you have
to apply something really quickly and
you don't have time to mess around with
spirit gum and stuff like that which is
often the case when we're filming here
for nostalgia critic or something like
that so I think they'll be pretty easy I
can put the tape on there and apply it
and it'll be easy to put on and remove
and stay on without a lot of sex so
that's about it for today I hope you
guys enjoyed this episode I guess that's
a pretty easiest with a pretty fast fun
cheap way to make doctor poisons mask
I'm using a cheap mask like I said you
could have used something like this if
you'd like it doesn't have quite the
contours and everything that this mask
can if you could find a mask like this
or when it's a little bit more highly
detailed and has some deeper cuts and
stuff like that in the face and in the
nose and everything that would give you
a little bit more of that contour and
some of the cool shadows and stuff like
that that her mask actually has that's
great but it's a fun fast cheap easy way
to make your death your poison costume
so once again thanks so much guys for
watching and I'll see you next time take
care
[Music]
you